[Musique]
j'ai déposé cette proposition de loi
pour un droit de visite effectif tout
simplement parce que la crise sanitaire
a été un énorme choc collectif et
qu'elle a révélé des faiblesses et parmi
ses faiblesses la plus préoccupante la
plus grave sans doute c'est ce
manquement au devoir d'humanité parce
que pendant de longs mois et bien après
le confinement des personnes fragiles
qu'elles soient handicapés malades ou
âgées ont été laissés seuls seuls face à
leurs derniers instants seul face à la
mort est seul aussi je dois le souligner
malgré le dévouement du personnel
soignant qui était totalement débordés
et ses réseaux pour laquelle à partir de
ce constat nous avons voulu instaurer un
vrai droit de visite un droit de visite
est effectif pour bien sûr les
établissements pour les personnes âgées
pour les malades par exemple dans les
hôpitaux dans les cliniques où
évidemment pour les personnes en fin de
vie et pour ces dernières nous avons
considéré que le droit de visite devait
être une obligation
inconditionnel
[Musique]
ce que je veux souligner c'est que nous
sommes capables au sénat sur un texte
qui n'était pas partisan eh bien nous
l'avons voté il n'y a pas eu une seule
voix contre ce qui est étonnant c'est le
gouvernement qui s'est opposé finalement
et ça souligne un côté technocratique
bureaucratique la question qui nous est
posée c est ce que oui ou non au nom de
la sécurité de tous tous veulent on
sacrifie la dignité l'humanité de chaque
personne derrière ce refus en réalité il
ya une sorte non pas de calcul mais une
approche qui est une approche finalement
très froides des questions d'un côté on
n'hésite pas avec des dizaines de
milliards à endetter la france et de
l'autre côté le droit de visite ne
nécessite aucun euro c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut simplement réaffirmé c'est
une règle qu'il faut ré institué voilà
et quant à la déliquance l'égalisation
bien sûr que ça coûte un peu d'argent
mais tellement moins que
les milliards qui sont dépensés chaque
jour en france on doit et c'est ce
qu'attendent les français aujourd'hui
veiller à ce que ces questions là qui
peuvent nous réunir d'ailleurs d'où que
nous venions je pense qu'on doit traiter
ces questions avec de l'humanité avec le
coeur